Martin uses the term stable to mean hard to change. Or, if you try to change it,
it's going to have many implications. Typically, a module's hard to change if
a lot of other modules depend on it. Martin's stable dependency principle
suggests that you should depend in the direction of stability. In other words,
no package should be dependent on packages that are more likely to
change than it is. This principle is similar to the previous one, that is, you
should depend downward and not introduce loops into the dependency hierarchy.
Note that we usually think of the term stable as a positive term but Martin is
treating it as undesirable. A corollary to this stable dependency principle
is Martin's Stable Abstraction Principle in which stable packages should be
abstract packages. The idea is that they're hard to change but easy to extend.